2018's superhero body count was impressive
to say the least, but 2019's promises to stack
at least as high - mostly thanks to the many
landmark movies, shows and comic storylines
that have been released over the course of
the year.
Obviously, there are spoilers ahead, and before
you ask about the MCU's Black Widow and Iron
Man, just remember that earlier this year
we covered superheroes who sadly died in the
first half of 2019, so if you want to see
them make sure you check out our previous
video!
After the whole Thanos thing that's been going
down in the MCU these last couple of years,
Marvel might be forgiven for thinking they
had the edge on killing off characters by
scrubbing them from existence.
But CW's The Flash begs to differ, since that's
how the speedster XS - also known as Nora
West-Allen - was killed off in the show's
season 5 finale.
During this episode, XS gets erased from reality
when Team Flash's defeat of the villain Cicada
changes Nora's future timeline.
In an earlier episode, the show's heroes learn
Nora has been running to and from the future,
getting tips on how to beat Cicada from the
imprisoned villain, Reverse-Flash.
But in the finale, the team figures out Reverse-Flash's
motivation - in the future, Cicada's dagger
keeps Reverse-Flash powerless, so he wants
Flash to destroy it.
Regardless of this discovery, the team is
forced to destroy Cicada's dagger.
Hoping to tie up loose ends, they then travel
to the future to stop Reverse-Flash.
The heroes seem to be winning the fight, but
Nora begins suffering the effects of the timeline
change.
Reverse-Flash tells the heroes the only way
to save Nora is for her to enter his "Negative
Speed Force," but she refuses - not wanting
to suffer from the negative emotions necessary
to access it.
Reverse-Flash escapes and Nora dies embracing
her mother and father.
You'd be on shaky ground calling Raven's comic
book counterpart - the Marvel version, not
the Teen Titan - a superhero, since she tends
to just veer between moral ambiguity and outright
villainy.
But ever since 2011's X-Men: First Class,
the movie franchise's Raven, also known as
Mystique, has been one of the good guys - and
she pays dearly for her heroics in 2019's
Dark Phoenix.
Shortly after Jean Grey leaves the mansion,
it becomes clear that Professor X not only
psychically blocked Jean's traumatic childhood
memories, but lied to her about the fate of
her father.
Because of this, Charles knows where to look
for Jean after she leaves - her father's home.
Once they find her, the X-Men are no match
for the emerging Phoenix.
She easily fights them off, even injuring
Quicksilver so badly he's benched for the
rest of the film.
When Raven tries to talk Jean down, an out-of-control
Jean flings Raven back through the air.
The blue-skinned mutant is impaled on a piece
of wreckage.
"I love you."
Raven's death brings with it catastrophic
consequences.
Magneto emerges to seek revenge on Phoenix,
Beast leaves the X-Men to help Magneto, and
the X-Men and Magneto's followers find themselves
on an all-too-familiar collision course.
Better known as the Hellfire Club's Black
Queen, the comic book version of Selene Gallio
doesn't even enjoy the occasional act of moral
ambiguity Mystique does - she's 100% bad guy.
But just like her actual abilities, the morality
of Dark Phoenix's Selene is vastly different
from the comic version.
The film first depicts Selene as one of the
inhabitants of the island Genosha, where Magneto
oversees a growing community of mutant refugees.
Along with Beast and Ariki, Magneto brings
Selene with him to New York City to kill Phoenix,
and she spends most of that fight using her
own telepathic abilities to keep Professor
X's powers busy.
After all the mutants are captured by a government
strike force and loaded onto a train, Selene
joins the X-Men against a horde of invading
aliens.
Unfortunately, Selene doesn't survive the
battle.
During a lull in the fight against the aliens…well,
this happens.
And sure, her body is never actually shown,
but since this version of the character isn't
nearly as powerful as her comic counterpart,
her fate is nonetheless clear enough.
As far as anyone knows, Melissa Benoist will
continue playing Supergirl well into the future,
but season 4 of Supergirl saw one of her characters
killed off nonetheless.
This season had Benoist doing double duty
as both Supergirl and a clone raised in the
fictional Eastern European nation of Kaznia.
The clone was initially referred to as Snowbird
and later nicknamed Red Daughter, referring
to the classic DC Elseworlds miniseries Superman:
Red Son, which had Kal-El raised in the Soviet
Union rather than Kansas.
Lex Luthor allies himself with the Kaznians
and uses the opportunity to manipulate Red
Daughter and win her loyalty.
Unfortunately, in Supergirl's season 4 finale,
Red Daughter learns Lex's loyalty only goes
one way.
Lex fools the Kaznians into believing he's
supporting an invasion of the United States,
when in fact he uses the opportunity to destroy
the invading Kaznians and falsely prove himself
as a hero to the U.S.
When Supergirl confronts Luthor with what
he's done, she finds herself needing Red Daughter's
help.
The clone eventually dies coming between Lex
and Supergirl, after Lex tries to blast the
show's hero with Kryptonite energy.
The Kryptonite kills Red Daughter, but as
she dies she releases a wave of energy - which
Supergirl uses to grow strong enough to finally
defeat Luthor.
The second episode of Amazon Prime's The Boys
sees the series claim its first superhero
victim, but it's far from the last.
Translucent is captured by the Boys after
he follows Hughie from the Seven's headquarters
and attacks him at his electronics store job.
Hughie and Billy Butcher manage to incapacitate
Translucent, but can't kill him because of
his super-dense skin.
Butcher then brings the unconscious hero to
his old colleague Frenchie, who eventually
has the idea to insert a bomb into the incapacated
hero.
With Hughie still new to life as an outlaw,
the notion of gruesomely killing Translucent
doesn't sit well with him.
And sure enough, towards the end of the second
episode, he waits until he's alone with the
hero and proceeds to free him from his cage.
But before Translucent can escape, Hughie
changes his mind and sets off the bomb inside
the supe, blowing him to smithereens.
The comic book The Boys is based on tends
to be much bloodier than the show, though
in this case the series handled Hughie's "christening"
into Butcher's world in a much darker fashion.
Like the show, Hughie is the first member
of the Boys to kill a supe in the comic - he
kills the young Blarney from the team Teenage
Kix.
But Blarney's death at Hughie's hands in the
comic is an accident, while the Hughie of
the show knows exactly what he's doing when
he kills Translucent.
The accidental death of Hughie's girlfriend
Robin by the speedster hero A-Train is what
sends Hughie on his quest for justice.
Before his death, Translucent reveals that
A-Train was with his girlfriend Popclaw before
he killed Robin.
The Boys would likely have never discovered
this on their own, as A-Train has been keeping
his relationship with Popclaw a secret because
she's seen as being something of a C-Lister
in the superhero community.
This news makes Popclaw a perfect target for
the Boys.
Posing as workmen, they plant surveillance
devices in her apartment, and when Popclaw
accidentally kills her landlord, the Boys
are there to blackmail her into giving them
information.
When A-Train later finds out that word has
got out about the drug Compound-V, he forces
Popclaw to go into hiding, worried that Homelander
might find out about her.
At the same time, A-Train correctly suspects
Popclaw might be the Boys' source for their
information.
When she finally admits what happened with
her landlord and the Boys, A-Train uses his
super speed to grab two syringes of heroin
and injects them into Popclaw before she can
stop him.
She then dies from the ensuing overdose.
The most brutal death in the first season
of The Boys is surely that of Mesmer, a mind-reading
former teen hero who has since fallen into
obscurity and been relegated to the convention
circuit.
"So what am I thinking of…"
"We're thinking of the same thing."
"Cool."
In episode 6, Frenchie and Mother's Milk track
down Mesmer at a convention and convince him
to help them.
In return, Mother's Milk promises to reunite
Mesmer with the daughter he hasn't seen in
years.
Butcher isn't happy when he finds out Frenchie
and Mother's Milk have gone to a supe for
help, however, and unfortunately his fears
come true.
By the end of the sixth episode, Mesmer has
given Homelander information on every last
one of the Boys, in the hopes it will win
him favor with the Seven and bring him back
to the inner circle of successful superheroes.
Homelander takes Mesmer's phone, which contains
photographs of the Boys, and flies off.
Of course, Mesmer's reward never materializes...at
least, not the one he was hoping for.
Butcher catches the psychic as he tries to
flee the city and beats him to death in a
public restroom - but not before he tells
Mesmer to use his powers on him, so the supe
can see exactly what Butcher's planning to
do to him.
If you've been following Titans' second season,
then you know something has been brewing with
the team regarding a past conflict with the
mercenary Deathstroke.
In the second season's fourth episode, things
finally kick off after Garth, also known as
Aqualad, is killed off.
Aqualad spends most of the episode trying
to woo Donna Troy, and it's clear he's had
a thing for her for years.
They finally sleep together toward the end
of the episode, but it's only hours before
Donna Troy plans to secretly leave Titans
Tower for Themyscira.
Once Dick Grayson tells Aqualad what Donna's
planning, Aqualad finds Donna at the airport
to profess his love and, he hopes, stop her
from leaving.
He catches Donna and her older mentor Jillian
before they get on the plane, and things look
hopeful for their young love...before Deathstroke
fires on them from a hidden position.
Garth turns and protects Donna from the bullet,
taking it in the chest and dying.
Donna and Jillian manage to escape, and by
the end of the episode Donna and the rest
of the Titans are ready to exact their vengeance.
The line-wide Marvel Comics story War of the
Realms was one of Marvel's biggest events
in 2019.
And in War of the Realms #2, Asgard loses
one of its favorite daughters - Valkyrie.
Fighting atop a pile of slain trolls and dark
elves, Valkyrie reaches out to Malekith, architect
of the War of the Realms, to stop hiding and
face her.
Malekith surprises her and stabs her from
behind, and the issue ends with the dark elf
mercilessly beheading her.
While this seems a conclusive end to a character
as you'll find in any Marvel comic, Malekith
doesn't rid the world of Valkyrie, though
he does kill Brunnhilde.
Three weeks before the release of War of the
Realms #2, Marvel's Editor-in-Chief CB Cebulski
announced at Chicago's C2E2 convention that
a new Valkyrie comic would spin out of War
of the Realms.
The day after issue two's release, news broke
that it would not be Brunnhilde's spirit would
pass the mantle of Valkyrie to Jane Foster.
Foster is played by Natalie Portman in the
MCU films, and in the comics took over the
mantle of Thor for four years, until being
forced to sacrifice Mjolnir to stop the monstrous
Mangog in 2018's Mighty Thor #705.
Last year, the MCU's Heimdall died at Thanos'
hands in the opening scene of Avengers: Infinity
War.
In Valkyrie: Jane Foster #2, Heimdall's comic
book counterpart dies as well, though the
villain who kills him isn't quite as powerful
as Thanos.
War of the Realms had come to an end by this
point, but the shockwaves are still being
felt across the universe.
Jane Foster replaced the late Brunnhilde as
Valkyrie at the end of the event, launching
her new solo series Valkyrie: Jane Foster.
In the first issue, Foster defeats some minor
villains who stole the original Valkyrie's
sword after her death, but one of them gets
away.
The sword, Dragonfang, is claimed by the psychotic
Daredevil villain Bullseye.
As the issue ends, Bullseye runs Heimdall
through with Dragonfang from behind.
Heimdall initially survives and helps Foster
battle the villain, but later dies from his
wounds after successfully destroying Dragonfang.
As he dies, he begs Foster not to take him
to Valhalla, but to bring him beyond the ten
realms so he can see what is there.
Foster agrees, promising to embark on a "Journey
Into Mystery" with the late bridge-keeper,
echoing the title of the comic in which Marvel's
Thor first appeared in 1962.
Tony Stark: Iron Man #15 sees the return of
an old friend to the Marvel universe: an artificial
intelligence version of Tony Stark.
"Oh, it's good to be back."
The Stark A.I. became active after the events
Civil War II left Tony in a coma.
It acted as a mentor to Riri WIlliams, also
known as Ironheart, and occupied one of Tony's
suits to help his friends against Hydra in
the Marvel-wide Secret Empire event.
The real Stark, now out of his coma, testifies
in front of Congress in Tony Stark: Iron Man
#15, and one of the senators has somehow gotten
his hands on the Stark A.I.
He reactivates it in the middle of the proceedings,
and when Iron Man is attacked by a bizarre
android comprised of the fused bodies of Vision
and Wonder Man, the A.I. is there to help
him.
Unfortunately, Tony knows the only thing that
will stop the android is an EMP cascade, which
will also kill off the A.I.
The Stark A.I. tells him to go through with
it anyway, sacrificing itself in the process.
But that's not all.
Since the beginning of Tony Stark: Iron Man,
Tony and his colleagues have been dealing
with the notion of whether or not artificial
intelligence deserve the same rights as humans.
While Stark is testifying, there are A.I.-driven
robots out protesting in the street...and
his EMP cascade kills off all of them as well.
With the deaths of Kid Loki and Valkyrie,
the Asgardians of the Galaxy arguably suffer
more than any other superhero team in Marvel's
War of the Realms event.
Asgardians of the Galaxy #10, the series finale,
takes one more victim from the Asgardians'
ranks, as Skurge the Executioner makes a last
stand that is brimming with dark irony.
Skurge was freshly resurrected when he joined
the Asgardians of the Galaxy, as his previous
death was one of the most memorable in Marvel
Comics history.
He died in the 1985 classic Thor #362, fighting
off waves of undead soldiers to give his Asgardian
brethren time to escape Hel.
"For Asgard…"
This time around, however, Skurge's foes are
much different.
The angels of Heven inexplicably side with
the Dark Elf Malekith in War of the Realms,
and Skurge ends up joining fellow Asgardian
Angela in Heven itself.
Once there, Skurge holds off the angels to
give Angela the time to summon an army of
undead Asgardian warriors.
Ironically, having died his first death against
an army of the dead, Skurge dies his second
death helping to summon another army of the
dead to his side.
After he succumbs to his wounds and the battle
is won, Skurge awakes in Valhalla, the realm
of the honored dead.
Valhalla's other residents greet him warmly,
and when he insists he hasn't earned a place
among them, they tell him they all thought
the same thing when they got there.
Dark Beast is a version of Hank McCoy from
an alternate reality based on the 1995 Age
of Apocalypse event - and, to be fair, he
wasn't much of a superhero.
Nevertheless, he's been working with the X-Men
since Cyclops returned from the dead and started
putting a new team together in Uncanny X-Men
#11.
In Uncanny X-Men #20, Dark Beast inadvertently
turns on his benefactors, thinking he's helping
them, but pays for his mistake with his life.
All around the globe, parents are giving their
children a new vaccine designed to suppress
any emerging mutant genes.
Dark Beast tells his teammates he's figured
out a way to counteract the vaccine.
He just needs his own agent dispersed in the
upper atmosphere.
Unfortunately, the X-Men trust Dark Beast,
and Banshee disperses the agent as ordered.
The X-Men soon learn what Dark Beast failed
to tell them: that, once his agent has been
dispersed, it wouldn't simply stop the anti-mutant
vaccine from working; if a child receiving
the vaccine is a mutant, it will likely kill
them.
Dark Beast sees this as an inestimable success,
saying that now human parents won't dare get
their children vaccinated.
Ignoring Cyclops' protests, the vengeful mutant
Magik uses her powers to teleport Dark Beast's
head into the ceiling, ending his dark experiments
for good.
The current volume of Guardians of the Galaxy
spun out of the line-wide event Infinity Wars
in which Gamora kills her adoptive father
Thanos.
In Guardians of the Galaxy #1 it is revealed
that Thanos had arranged to have his consciousness
uploaded into someone else's body in case
of his untimely death.
Starfox then assembles a team of "Dark Guardians"
to find and kill the most likely candidates,
starting with Gamora - while Peter Quill's
Guardians try to save her.
Unfortunately for Starfox and his Dark Guardians,
it turns out Gamora isn't the new host for
Thanos after all.
In Guardians of the Galaxy #5, it's revealed
that it was Starfox into whom Thanos' consciousness
was uploaded, and it was the Asgardian goddess
of death, Hela, who did the deed.
After the Dark Guardians capture Gamora, Hela
appears and easily brushes them aside.
She reveals the truth to Starfox and Thanos'
consciousness emerges and gains dominance
over his brother's body.
Hela then brings Starfox to Knowhere, where
Thanos' reassembled body awaits.
The Guardians arrive on Knowhere, and Gamora
runs Starfox through - ending his life and
stopping the Mad Titan's resurrection.
The long-awaited CW crossover "Crisis on Infinite
Earths" finally arrived as 2019 approached
its end, and the event's first chapter wasted
no time in taking a major victim.
Oliver Queen, a.k.a. Green Arrow.
He sacrifices himself in the first episode
to save the population of the besieged Earth-38,
home of the Arrowverse's Supergirl.
As anti-matter waves threaten to destroy all
the universes in the multiverse, heroes from
most of the CW's superhero series are summoned
by the Monitor to save Earth-38 and evacuate
over 3 billion of its people to Earth-1.
As the heroes fight off the Anti-Monitor's
armies, the Monitor determines Earth-38 is
lost and transports the heroes away.
Green Arrow, however, refuses to leave.
The Monitor finally brings Oliver back to
Earth-1.
"I calculate 1 billion souls survived due
to his noble sacrifice."
Oliver dies shortly afterward.
But he does get resurrected, sort of, in part
3, he's brought back without a soul.
After a group of heroes goes to Purgatory
to save him, Jim Corrigan, The Spectre in
the comics, tells him that he's needed elsewhere
to fulfill his destiny.
By Part Three of "Crisis on Infinite Earths,"
all the heroes of the multiverse are dead.
The only survivors are Supergirl, Batwoman,
Ryan Choi, Lex Luthor, Flash, J'onn J'onzz,
and Sara Lance.
Titans' Hawk and Robin of Earth-9, the 1960s
Batman series' Earth-66 Robin, and Birds of
Prey's Earth-203 Huntress, and everyone from
their respective worlds, are all annihilated
by the anti-matter wave, Batwoman kills the
Earth-99 Batman, and Lex Luthor kills and
replaces the Earth-96 Superman.
Earth-90 Flash sacrifices himself to save
Earth-1, which unfortunately proves futile
after the Harbinger kills The Monitor.
The long list of other dead heroes include
everyone on Earth-2, Earth-89 Batman and any
members of his Bat family, the Ray and Freedom
Fighters of Earth-X, the Mick Rory of Earth-74,
the heroes of Earth-38, the former Superman
and other heroes of Earth-167, Black Lightning,
Thunder, Lightning, Pariah, and Jonah Hex.
Those aren't all the superheroes who lost
their lives in 2019.
Here are a few other heroes who fell this
year.
Scout
Waxman
Gibbon
Joseph
Star Boy
Vanisher
Velocidad
Alejandra Jones
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.